we're in New Hampshire before the
primary where Bernie Sanders and Donald
Trump have stolen the hearts of many
voters but we wanted to know what's on
their minds and welcome to the aj+ desk
of important thoughts why would you lean
towards Bernie Sanders over Hillary
Clinton he is for the next generation I
feel he walks the walk and that's the
biggest difference he poses a lot of
natural gas pipelines going around the
area as a woman I really struggled with
wanting to go with Hillary but I just
can't get over the fact that she has so
many ties to Monsanto is going to take
care of the veterans he's going to take
care of the poor he wants to make them
ever per grade again and I want to live
to see that you feel like he represents
you yes but now are you a billionaire
sir no he doesn't care when it come to
political correctness he speaks his mind
there's a lot of Islamic terrorism going
on around the world which I was
president and never admits and what if
let's say nationally Trump doesn't win
what are your thoughts on the other
candidates it would be Bernie Santa's
really a family tell me why I like him
he he's more sincere we need better
screening of who's coming into the
country oh I absolutely believe there's
Isis cells in every state in this
country I get phone calls in my home
phone three four times a week from
Islamic people trying to seek out
whether or not I am a supporter
and Christian I usually they don't want
you those various phone companies or
something no absolutely not now I'm sama
liam is not saying I want you to switch
our company